a las vegas couple celebrating a huge
milestone today
janet and melvin swanson married 75
years ago
and now they have some secrets for our
viewers for long-lasting marriage
8 news now reporter victoria saha has
the details
more than seven decades ago janet and
melvin swanson
locked eyes for the first time
i know that darren i love you too we met
in his brother's restaurant
standing in the doorway i looked at him
he looked at me
and that was it he went home with me i
said
turn back the clock at midnight because
it's going to be your night
three weeks later on may 14th they were
married janet 17
and melvin 20. he went from l.a to
las vegas and got married and drove back
home again real quick because he
shipped out the next day 75 years later
even a pandemic couldn't keep the couple
apart
when melvin's nursing home had to stop
visitors
janet still continued to visit her
husband through a window
every day eight news now was there for
their 74th anniversary
it pleased me to come here every day and
see
even if it was through the glass window
threw a glass window at least i saw him
he was healthy last year on their
anniversary the pandemic forced the
swansons to be apart for the first time
in 74 years they couldn't embrace each
other
making this 75th anniversary extra
special
and their secret to a long happy
marriage
love and don't cheat
bring some money home and a little
humor i loved her hair
nice girl's hair
it looks bad now i think what
your hair my hair yeah oh well remind me
to look right in your face when you get
back in the room
victoria saha 8 news now
they're so cute janet says she will
continue to visit her husband
every day as long as she's healthy